Oh...
And no settings on.
Oopsie!
Do you guys like my outfit?
Cute?
I'm the Christmas bear.
Wait, hold on.
YouTube.
There we go.
I am the Christmas bear.
You like it?
Kawaii.
Kawaii!
I hope Minto is one of the spirits that visits.
Well, which one do you want me to be?
Do you want me to be the spirit of the Christmas...
Wait...
Future?
Past?
Present?
Minto kawaii.
The famous Christmas bear.
Yeah, obviously.
Be the ghost of my future.
Wow, that's kind of smooth.
Wait.
Wow.
Sure.
Kiriha?
Damn.
Dang.
That was pretty good.
There we go.
Anyways guys, welcome to my karaoke!
It's...
It's Christmas time!
Actually, we can finally sing Christmas songs for real.
Upside down Lampy.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you!
Not normal Lampy.
Upside down.
Minky, how is kitty?
Kitty is good!
For those who don't know, I had to take my cat to the vet.
Butaro, my older kitty.
Not Paz, my newer kitty.
He has been having issues with a little thing on his arm.
And it's infected.
And I noticed it was infected on Thanksgiving.
And I was like, no!
And they weren't open until today.
So I got him in today.
And the doctor was like, oh...
I think...
Okay, so I have like three options.
He's like, if it's cancerous...
You'll just have to keep doing surgery to get it cut off.
And if it's...
And you can do radiation, but he was like, I don't recommend it.
And I was like, I don't want to do that.
My cat's too old.
He doesn't want to do radiation.
Or you can cut off his arm.
He was like, you can just keep getting surgery to get the tumor, whatever it is, cut off.
Or you can amputate his arm.
I'm so...
So Butaro's kind of going through it.
Because he has like a cancer in his tummy too.
But I don't think they're related.
He thinks that maybe it's a type of tumor.
If it is cancerous, it's localized.
That is not a hot dog moment!
Oh, sorry.
I realized my notice was turned off.
Um...
Uh, localized to his arm.
So...
I got a dog's arm removed and she did great.
Yeah, I don't...
This is...
I went to see what her options are first.
So, you know.
Yeah, he's old.
I don't want to take his arm off.
So, you know.
He's been in a cone and he's been sad.
So I've been sad for him.
Sorry, I didn't want to start the stream like this.
I'm feeling a little more optimistic about it than pessimistic.
Because he's been...
Overall, he's been good.
Even today, he was playing with Paz.
So, you know.
And he's still eating and drinking and doing just fine.
Just has a little bit of a rough time.
Announcement, good.
My cat has cancer.
No!
No, he's...
They're still...
They're still playing and he's been good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But that's...
This is not the announcement, by the way.
This is not the announcement.
Oh my gosh, my computer's been so slow today.
I do not know why.
The announcement will be in...
Sometime.
I can't give it to you right away.
I can't give it to you right now.
We have to sing first.
We must sing for the announcement.
Oh my gosh.
Which I have...
Wanting to do in like 15...
No, sorry.
Wait, what?
Let's sing a song!
I didn't say anything.
Let's sing a Christmas song!
What's a Christmas song we can sing first?
Back from Japan, can watch streams again.
David, I saw you post some pictures around Akiba.
They were so good.
Jingle bells!
Spooky scary skeletons.
That's a Christmas song!
Or, I say Christmas.
Winter too.
Jingle bell rock!
Alright, let's sing a jingle bell rock.
I don't know which one is a good one to sing.
Let's sing...
Whatever this one is.
I didn't warm up as I usually don't before a stream.
Oopsie.
So, I might have to warm up a bit.
Jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell rock.
Jingle bells swing and jingle bells ring.
Snowing and blowing up bushels of fun.
Now the jingle hop has begun.
Jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell rock.
Jingle bells chime in jingle bell time.
Dancing and prancing in jingle bell square.
In the frosty air.
What a bright time, it's the right time.
To rock the night away.
Jingle bell time is a swell time.
To go gliding in a one horse sleigh.
Giddy up jingle horse, pick up your feet.
Jingle around the clock.
Mix... mix?
Jingle in feet.
That's the jingle bell rock.
Jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell rock.
Jingle bell chime in jingle bell time.
Dancing and prancing in jingle bell square.
In the frosty air.
What a bright time, it's the right time.
To rock the night away.
A hock to a hock.
Swell time.
To go gliding in a one horse sleigh.
Giddy up jingle horse, pick up your feet.
Jingle around the clock.
Mix and a mingle in the jingling feet.
That's the jingle bell.
That's the jingle bell rock.
I've only seen like the ones... For some reason I keep seeing them being made of blue archive.
Like why?
Jingle bell rock of the skibbity skibbity hock to a hock.
That one, you know.
I'm putting you in a trash compactor.
And this is only 50% cute aggression?
What?
Stop!
Shut up!
What are you talking about?
Paddle, paddle.
Hashi de sori yo.
Kaze no you ni.
Tsukimi haraba.
Paddle, paddle.
Everytime you sing I'm reminded you have a voice of an angel.
No!
What are you talking about?
That was way too high for me.
Rotate to a 45 degree angle and leave you there.
No!
Do you happen to know Little Saint Nick by the Beach Boys?
That's the one that's like Little Saint Nick.
Little Saint Nick.
Thank you Daryl.
It's a Little Saint Nick.
Little Saint Nick.
Happy December.
Happy December!
People talk about Mariah, but for me December is when Nero is released.
Paddle, paddle.
Do you want a hippopotamus?
Let's do it!
I want a hippopotamus for Christmas.
Metronome!
Thank you so much for the Akatono.
Akasupa.
How can an angel with such a cute voice have such terminal brain rot?
Sorry I have the brain rot.
Merry Christmas Finto.
Merry Christmas!
It's only December 2nd, but you know...
You know.
It's Christmas season.
We gotta get into the season early, you know.
Hayden, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
Let's do it.
Christmas hippopotamus.
Who came up with this idea?
I want a hippopotamus for Christmas.
Only a hippopotamus will do.
I don't want a doll, no dinky dinker toy.
I want a hippopotamus to play with and enjoy.
I want a hippopotamus for Christmas.
I don't think Santa Claus will mind, do you?
He won't have to use our dirty chimney flue.
Just bring him through the front door, that's the easy thing to do.
I can see me now on Christmas morning, creeping down the stairs.
Oh, what joy and what surprise when I open up my eyes to see a hippo hero standing there.
I want a hippopotamus for Christmas.
Only a hippopotamus will do.
No crocodiles or rhinoceroses.
I only like hippopotamuses.
And hippopotamuses like me too.
How do you spell hippopotamus?
Oh, I wonder, hippo.
Mom says the hippo would eat me up but then.
Teacher says a hippo is a vegetarian.
Is that true?
There's a lot of room for him in our two-car garage.
I'll feed him there and wash him there and give him a massage.
I can see me now on Christmas morning, creeping down the stairs.
Oh, what joy and what surprise when I open up my eyes to see a hippo hero standing there.
I want a hippopotamus for Christmas.
Only a hippopotamus will do.
No crocodiles or rhinoceroses.
I only like hippopotamuses.
And hippopotamuses like me too.
Hippo... wait.
Hippo... hippopotamus.
I want a hippopotamus for Christmas.
Did I spell that right?
You fell from heaven.
Stop!
No.
I'm a ghost.
Hippo... hippopotamus.
It's correct, right?
I... I think it's right.
It meant it was my birthday and I'm excited for the news.
It may have been a rough holiday weekend, but getting a karaoke for my Kamiyoshi makes it special nonetheless.
VALDI, HAPPY BIRTHDAY!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy... Oh, two birthdays!
Happy birthday dear Valdi.
Happy birthday to you.
Wait.
And Mish!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Mish.
Happy birthday!
Also, welcome from LimeMoose community.
Hello, hello, hello.
Thank you for the Haka, it's super!
Feliz Navidad.
Okay, I can sing a Feliz Navidad.
And then I don't have to sing just only English or Spanish.
I can sing in Japanese too.
I guess this counts as English kind of.
Probably.
But it's Spanish.
She did you so dirty during crab game.
I know!
Liz!
Oh my gosh, hello!
You look super cute.
Stop it.
You are so beautiful.
I want to see you in this too.
I want to see you perfectly because you are red.
Feliz Navidad.
Let's sing it.
Thank you for the gifted you guys.
Thank you!
For some reason my chat is like all messed up.
Like my computer is kind of slow today.
I'm sorry.
So it's hard for me to scroll up and if I miss something...
Feliz Navidad.
Prospero año y felicidad.
I want to wish you a Merry Christmas.
I want to wish you a Merry Christmas from the bottom of my heart.
I wish you a Merry Christmas.
I want to wish you a Merry Christmas.
I want to wish you a Merry Christmas from the bottom of my heart.
Feliz Navidad.
It's kind of high.
Feliz Navidad, prospero año y felicidad Feliz Navidad, feliz Navidad, feliz Navidad, prospero año y felicidad I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas From the bottom of my heart I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas From the bottom of my heart Feliz Navidad,
feliz Navidad Feliz Navidad, prospero año y felicidad
I want to wish you a Merry Christmas.
I want to wish you a Merry Christmas from the bottom of my heart.
Feliz Navidad.
Prospero año y felicidad.
Oh, that's it?
Frogbert?
No.
I mean I could do Frogbert version of something.
Oh, someone sent this one.
This one.
Grandma got run over by a rain.
Did I spell that right?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK.
When is a very Minto Christmas album dropping?
Let's do this one.
Good Spanish.
Thank you.
Gracias.
Grandma got run over by a reindeer.
Walking home from our house Christmas Eve.
You can say there's no such thing as Santa.
But as for me and Grandpa, we believe.
She'd been drinking too much eggnog.
And we begged her not to go.
Oh, Grandma.
But she forgot her medication.
And she staggered out the door into the snow.
When we found her Christmas morning.
At the scene of the attack.
Oh my God!
She had hoof prints on her forehead.
And incriminating claw marks on her back.
Grandma got run over by a reindeer.
Walking home from our house Christmas Eve.
You can say there's no such thing as Santa.
But as for me and Grandpa, we believe.
Now we're all so proud of Grandpa.
He's been taking this so well.
See him in there watching football.
Drinking beer and playing cards with Cousin Mel.
It's not Christmas without Grandma.
All the family's dressed in black.
And we just can't help but wonder.
Should we open up her gifts or send them back?
Oh no!
Grandma got run over by a reindeer.
Santa walking home from our house Christmas Eve.
You can say there's no such thing as Santa.
But as for me and Grandpa, we believe.
Now the goose is on the table.
So sad.
And the pudding's made of fig.
And the blue and silver candles.
That would just have matched the hair in Grandma's wig.
I've warned all my friends and neighbors.
Better watch out for yourselves.
They should never give a license.
To a man who drives a sleigh and plays with elves.
Oh no!
Grandma got run over by a reindeer.
Walking home from our house Christmas Eve.
Now you can say there's no such thing as Santa.
But as for me and Grandpa, we believe.
Grandma got run over by a reindeer.
Walking home from our house Christmas Eve.
You can say there's no such thing as Santa.
But as for me and Grandpa, we believe.
I should have gone higher.
I didn't realize it.
I thought I was going to say something else.
Feliz Navidad and Grandma got run over by a reindeer.
Yay!
Alrighty guys.
Hold on one moment please.
Sorry I was reading what was on the screen.
I will wait for a few moments.
Perhaps.
I will wait maybe a few minutes.
Yes.
Someone.
Birthday.
More birthday.
I'm glad to have a Minto karaoke on my birthday.
I will always enjoy your singing.
Thank you someone.
One more time.
I hope you... I misspelled reindeer.
No I didn't.
Thank you for the Haka Shoputo.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear someone.
One more time.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Devious Paul!
Happy birthday, everybody!
So many birthdays, so many birthdays.
Alrighty.
Someone said another song.
Cannot unhear the gramps got run over by a seme.
What?
Yaoi?
Santar.
Santar is... yeah.
Santar, Santar.
Sing that version.
I don't know that version.
I don't know the Yaoi Christmas carols.
I have no idea.
When is Yaoi Christmas carol?
I guess I have to do a part 2.
And learn all the Yaoi versions of these songs.
What?
Santar.
Last Christmas?
I feel like I don't know this song very well, but I'll sing it.
What movies do you have lined up for Christmas?
Die Hard?
I don't know.
I'm doing a members watch along of Indiana Jones on Friday.
I had no idea.
I completely didn't even plan this.
But on Friday is the release of the Indiana Jones game!
So I think I have to... I think I have to... I don't know.
I want to play the Indiana Jones game.
So I'm like, which movies?
1 through 3?
Yeah, 1 through 3.
So I'm like, maybe I play Indiana Jones in the morning and then members watch along.
I thought that was intentional.
No!
I just... I have... I have Indie vision.
I have Indie brain.
I had no idea.
So I'm like, what do I do?
All I want for Christmas is you.
We'll get to that one.
We have to work ourselves up to that one, right?
Davey's song from Eight Crazy Nights.
I don't know it.
That one.
Hold on.
One second.
Ok.
Guys, I have an announcement to make.
I guess I'll make it now.
So that I... Oh, I gotta change my timer.
Oh gosh.
Actually, let's sing one more song and then I'll do the announcement.
Ok, one second.
Let me do one more song and then I'll do...
Let's do...
What's a 3 minute song?
Christmas.
Let me just search Christmas.
There.
Oh no, now I need 2 minutes.
Jingle bells!
There we go.
I'm gonna turn the key up though.
Oh wait.
Jingle bells!
Wait, I was wrong.
Let me turn the key down.
There we go.
It sounds demonic now.
Laughing all the way.
Bells on bobtails ring.
Making spirits bright.
What fun it is to laugh and sing a sleighing song tonight.
Jingle bells!
Jingle all the way.
Oh what fun it is to ride in a one horse open sleigh.
Jingle bells!
Jingle all the way.
Oh what fun it is to ride in a one horse open sleigh.
A day or two ago, I thought I'd take a ride.
And soon Miss Fanny Bright was seated at my side.
The horse was lean and lank.
Misfortune seemed his lot.
We got into a drifted bank and then we got upside.
Jingle bells!
Is the horse okay?
Oh what fun it is to ride in a one horse open sleigh.
Jingle bells!
Jingle all the way.
Oh what fun it is to ride in a one horse open sleigh.
Dashing through the snow in a one horse open sleigh.
Over the fields we go, laughing all the way.
Bells on bobtails ring.
Making spirits bright.
What fun it is to laugh and sing a sleighing song tonight.
Jingle bells!
Jingle all the way.
Oh what fun it is to ride in a one horse open sleigh.
Jingle bells!
Jingle all the way.
Oh what fun it is to ride in a one horse open sleigh.
Oh, okay, sorry.
I thought we were going to do the dramatic like...
One horse open sleigh.
You know?
Okay, nevermind.
Guys, I have an announcement.
The announcement is that in...
My first ever my own merch drop.
In 20 minutes the site will open.
And you can purchase such things as...
Such things as...
Things that I announced back in June.
And such as... Wait, I have nothing prepared.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, the link!
Yes, the link.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
The link is...
Wait, you guys got to stop the chat.
Because I have to...
It's pinned!
Now, replace the pinned message.
Oh, sorry, I just realized my pinned message was still about my cat.
I was like, why are so many people asking about my cat?
Shop.moso.moe.sashamintophantom You can't see the stuff right now, but there's actually also...
Some other things that are...
That are new as well.
Things that...
That I didn't announce before.
So...
What's the test?
Oh, test, yeah.
Test.
So, there will be things such as my first plushie.
The little tiny Minto plushie.
And things like...
Like... This is the only picture I have available.
Oh my gosh.
My... This thingy.
Which is a...
Like a Lego block version of me.
And...
Oh gosh, I'm nervous.
Sorry.
I have no pictures of plushie...
Of little plushie Minto.
But trust, she's cute.
And...
There's some other things as well.
Some other things that Moso...
Moso helped with organizing.
So, not just those things.
And Dakimakura should be up...
Soon-ish, I think.
Dakimakura, I think, is a different link.
It might be on there.
I'm not quite sure what's going on.
But...
Also...
The Dakimakura is a limited time thing.
So, you have until the end of the month to order it.
Order should be going out...
Sometime next month.
So...
Yes, yes.
Legally distinct interlocking plastic blocks.
Yes.
It's actually another company called Mythical Blocks.
I'm their first ever western Vtuber.
That they are working with.
Is everything limited in number?
Plushies and...
Mint blocks are limited in number.
Yes, I believe the mint blocks...
I don't know if they will ever restock.
So...
Yeah.
You know.
So...
Plushies, I would love to restock those, you know, obviously.
What did I just sing?
Oh, Jingle Bells.
Sorry, I'm nervous.
I'm nervous.
I'm nervous, okay.
Wait.
Oh!
Daki will be up.
Okay, thank you.
I got confirmation.
Oh, here, hold on.
They're sending me photos.
Can I show the other things too?
There's some other little cute goodies in there.
This is the...
This is the Bagel Plush.
Bagel Minto Plushies.
There are many of them.
So...
Trust that you can get one.
I believe in you.
There are many of them.
There are many, many that I ordered.
So trust.
Maybe I'll leave the other things for a surprise, actually.
Like the...
There's some, like I said, there's some other cute things.
And yeah.
Oh, I should not hide the countdown.
All these...
Wait, actually, let me bring that back.
These will all be up...
In 15 minutes.
So let's keep singing.
And then I'll take a break.
So I guess you can get some stuff if you want to.
Oh.
What do you mean?
Maybe.
No!
Not here.
Will there be a bundle option?
I tried to.
Unfortunately, I do not have a bundle option.
I don't think.
I don't know.
You have many questions.
I'll take 10.
Bye, bye, bye.
If you want, you know.
No worries if you can't.
Oh, and yes, there is international shipping.
Yes, yes.
So, yes, international shipping.
Okay.
Moso has been so awesome with helping me out with setting up a store.
And doing fulfillment and everything.
And all this for me.
So, I very much appreciate their help.
And sorry it took so long for merch.
But we're here, baby.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm doing my best.
I am doing my best, that's all.
Yes, but hopefully you guys can enjoy some stuff.
Thank you for the 20 gifts.
Thank you.
I've never done my own merch drop before.
And I knew very quickly when I ordered stuff.
Such as the plushies and the mythical blocks.
That I was way in over my head.
So, yes.
My first ever merch drop.
In 12 minutes.
Hello, everybody.
Let's sing a song to welcome in the raiders.
What's a winter song we can sing?
What's a song we can sing?
We love you too much to make this easy for you.
What do you mean by that?
Santa baby?
Okay.
That's the Ariana Grande song, right?
Wait, is it Ariana Grande?
The Santa baby.
Oh no, that's Santa tell me.
Santa tell me.
I know.
Santa baby.
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
And someone else.
Okay.
Santa baby.
I think I know this one.
Pretty sure I know this one.
Santa baby, just slip a sable under the tree for me.
Been an awful good girl, Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
Santa baby, a 54 convertible too, light blue.
I'll wait up for you, dear Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
Think of all the fun I've missed.
Think of all the fellas that I haven't kissed.
Next year I could be just as good.
If you check off my Christmas list, Santa baby, I want a yacht and not really that...
Wait, wait, and really that's not a lot.
Can't read.
Been an angel all year, Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
This song is just asking for a bunch of expensive stuff.
Santa honey, one little thing I really need, the deed.
To a platinum mine, Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
Santa cutie, and fill my stocking with the duplex and checks.
Sign your X on the line, Santa cutie, and hurry down the chimney tonight.
Come and trim my Christmas tree with some decorations bought at Tiffany's.
I really do believe in you, let's see if you believe in me.
Santa baby, forgot to mention one little thing, a ring.
I don't mean on the phone, Santa baby, so hurry down the chimney tonight.
Hurry down the chimney tonight.
Hurry...tonight.
It's too embarrassing!
No!
Oh my gosh, Santa baby.
It's too embarrassing.
Song is about Santa's Discord kitten.
You have the perfect baby doll voice.
What does that mean?
Driving home for Christmas, I don't know if I know that one actually.
Team Red, welcome to my workshop.
Thank you.
It's a Marilyn Monroe song.
Is it?
Oh, I do see Ariana Grande covered that one.
Let's see if you believe in me.
I thought about it too.
I was like, do you believe in ghosts?
Let's do this one.
I think I know this one.
Sorry, my voice is a little...
Let's try it.
For Christmas, you can plan on me.
Please have snow and mistletoe and presents on the tree.
Christmas Eve will find me where the love light gleams.
I'll be home for Christmas If only in my dreams.
Be home for Christmas.
You can plan on me.
Please have snow and mistletoe and presents.
Oh, sands on the tree.
Christmas Eve will find me.
Light gleams.
I'll be home for Christmas.
If only in my dreams.
Four minutes.
Four minutes left.
That one was a different version.
Be home for Christmas.
That was a different version than what I'm used to, I feel.
I feel.
It's a little different.
Up on the rooftop.
Yeah!
I think this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Up on the rooftop.
I used to do Christmas carols at the old people's homes.
I'd be like, I'm a ghost!
See you soon!
Up on the housetop, reindeer paws.
What is that?
Oh, Santa Claus.
Down through the chimney with lots of toys.
All for the little ones, Christmas joy.
What is the tune?
Hold on.
Who wouldn't go?
Oh, oh, oh.
Up on the housetop.
Click, click, click.
Down through the chimney with ones.
Good Saint Nick.
It's old, right?
I thought he was old.
Not good.
First come the stocking of little Nell.
Oh, dear Santa, fill it well.
Give her a dolly that laughs and cries.
One that will open and shut her eyes.
Oh, oh, oh.
Sorry, I thought he was old.
Who wouldn't go?
Up on the housetop.
Click, click, click.
Down through the chimney with good Saint Nick.
Oh, oh, oh.
Who wouldn't go?
Up on the housetop.
Click, click, click.
Down through the chimney with good Saint Nick.
I'm trying to be all dramatic and these instrumentals are not letting me.
I'm trying to hit the high notes here.
Up on the house... on the e-house.
Up on the housetop.
Click, click, click.
Oh, oh, oh.
Sorry.
Oh, my gosh.
Tiktok is playing.
We have one minute, you guys.
I'm gonna go grab a snack.
And... Actually, I'm just gonna... Actually, I can eat some here.
I have a snack here.
I have some Jagarico.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, it's almost time though.
It's almost time.
Wait, let me see.
Wait, maybe it is time.
Wait, hold on.
Let me check the website.
Hold on.
Oh, no.
It's coming soon.
OK.
One minute left.
I think my computer is a little fast.
Sorry.
OK.
Let me put on some music while I chomp.
Sorry, I started to get... I started to get shaky hungry.
The link is pinned message.
The link is in the pinned message, everybody.
I really think it'll be fine on stock.
Gotta keep that blood sugar up.
I know.
The website is dead?
No, I don't think so.
I don't think so.
Sorry, I'm eating.
I'm refreshing too.
I'm nervous.
Is it up?
The website is down?
Oh, the site crashed.
While we wait, I can show you some of the other things.
I can show you some of the other fun merchandise things.
Oh, no.
The other extra things as well.
Hold on.
Let me actually put this all in like a...
In like a slideshow.
That might be better.
OK, hold on.
Let me save them.
That might be better.
Save.
I'm sorry.
But for now, let me share with you the things that...
Besides the block and the plushie, we have...
We have a keychain!
So cute.
Look how cute, cute, cute we have a keychain.
Very, very cute.
We have...
We have the vinyl sticker.
We got the art.
We got the permission from Oro...
For a sticker.
I think many people liked this one.
So you can now own it as a sticker.
We have a diorama of me in a little cafe.
So cute.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Very, very cute.
And then lastly we have...
Some acrylic magnets!
So you can have me coming from your walls.
I'm in your walls and I'm peeping out of your walls.
Or your fridge.
Or wherever you want to put me.
Very cute.
Very, very cute.
It's a set of four.
Yeah.
Originally they sent me some sketches for the four of them.
And they were like, which one would you like?
And I was like, I want all of them please.
So, yay!
We have these as well.
That are in the merch drop.
Oh gosh, I'm nervous.
Is it up yet?
They said they even upgraded the site, the server.
But it's still crashing.
No way.
How many of you are trying to even get on there?
One at a time.
Single file.
All of us.
Should we sing another song?
Thank you for the superchats, by the way.
Have more snack monies.
Sorry for crunching in your ears, you guys.
I'm really sorry if it's...
Sing another song?
Let's sing another song.
What should we sing?
Let's sing another Christmas winter song.
I'm gonna need a little bit more though.
Hold on, sorry.
I need some more.
My ectoplasm is low.
Ectoplasm low.
I'm here for Christmas.
Oh my gosh, yeah!
What are you munching on?
Some veggie chips.
Buddy, what are you munching on?
Snacks, buddy.
Nightmare before Christmas.
I'm gonna... Let's see.
How can I move these?
Let's make this one a bit smaller.
And move this up and move this over here.
Perfect.
Alright.
But not a Halloween song.
We'll do this one.
What's this?
There's color everywhere.
There's white things in the air.
What's this?
I can't believe my eyes.
I must be dreaming.
Wake up, Minto!
This isn't fair!
What's this?
There's something very wrong.
There's people singing songs.
What's this?
The streets are lined with little creatures laughing.
Everybody seems so happy.
Have I possibly gone daffy?
What is this?
What's this?
There's children throwing snowballs instead of throwing heads.
They're busy building toys and absolutely no one's dead.
There's frost on every window.
I can't believe my eyes.
And in my bones, I feel the warmth that's coming from inside.
Oh, look.
What's this?
They're hanging mistletoe.
They kiss?
Why, that looks so unique.
It's fire!
They're gathering around to hear a story.
Roasting chestnuts on a fire.
What's this?
I can't speak.
And here, they've got a little tree.
How queer!
And who would ever think?
And why?
They're covering it with tiny little things.
They've got electric light on strings and there's a smile on everyone.
So now, correct me if I'm wrong.
This looks like fun.
Oh, could it be I got my wish?
What's this?
Oh my, what now?
The children are asleep.
But look, there's nothing underneath.
No ghouls, no witches here to scream and scare them or ensnare them.
Only little cozy things secure inside their dreamland.
What's this?
I was early!
The monsters are all missing and the nightmares can't be found.
And in their place, there seems to be good feeling all around.
Instead of screams, I swear I can hear music in the air.
The smell of cakes and toys are absolutely everywhere.
The sights, the sounds, they're everywhere and all around.
I've never felt so good before.
This empty place inside of me is filling up.
I simply cannot get enough.
I want it.
Oh, I want it.
Oh, I want it for my own.
I got to know it.
It's this place that I have found.
What is this?
Christmas Town?
I sound like...I became an eagle for a second.
I became an eagle for a second.
What is this?
Need a song or two is what they said.
Another song!
I like this one too.
Of course I'm not going to stop after the merch though.
I'm going to sing a lot of songs.
No worries.
Actually, do I remember how this goes?
I think so.
Kidnap Mr. Sandy Claws.
I want to do it.
Let's draw straws.
Jack said we should work together.
Three of a kind.
Birds of a feather.
Now and forever.
Kidnap the Sandy Claws.
Lock him up real tight.
Throw away the key and then turn off all the lights.
First we're gonna set some bait inside a nasty trap and wait.
When he comes a-sniffing we will snap the trap and close the gate.
Wait, I've got a better plan to catch this big red lobster man.
Let's pop him in a boiling pot and when he's done we'll butter him up.
Kidnap the Sandy Claws.
Throw him in a box.
Bury him for 90 years then see if he talks.
Oh, then who's your oogie boogie man?
Can take the whole thing over then.
He'll be so pleased I do declare.
That he will cook him rare.
Woo!
Kidnap.
Kidnapping is very Christmas.
We take a can and aim it at his door and then not three times.
And when he answers, Sandy Claws will be no more.
You're so stupid.
Think now if we blow him up to smithereens.
We may lose some pieces and then Jack will beat us black and green.
Kidnap the Sandy Claws.
Tie him in a bag.
Throw him in the ocean then see if he is sad.
Because Mr. Oogie Boogie is the meanest guy around.
If I were on his boogie list, I'd get out of town.
He'll be so pleased by our success.
That he'll reward us too I bet.
Perhaps he'll make his special brew.
A snake and spider stew.
We're little henchmen and we take our job with pride.
We do our best to please him and stay on his good side.
I wish my cohorts weren't so dumb.
I'm not the dumb one.
You're no fun.
Shut up.
Make me.
I've got something.
Listen now.
This one is real good you'll see.
We'll send a present to his door.
Upon there'll be a notary.
Now in the box we'll wait and hide until his curiosity incises him to look inside and then we'll have him.
One, two, three.
Kidnap the Sandy Claws.
Beat him with a stick.
Lock him up for 90 years.
See what makes him tick.
Kidnap the Sandy Claws.
Choke him into bits.
Mr. Oogie Boogie is sure to get his kicks.
Kidnap the Sandy Claws.
See what we will see.
Lock him in a cage and then throw away the way the key.
That was fun.
I want to kidnap Santa Claus now.
I mean, sorry, the Sandy Claws.
Legally distinct Santa Claus.
Kidnap the Sandy Claws.
She's arguing with herself.
I literally stopped taking my meds for that song.
I wasn't arguing with myself.
Legally distinct Santa Claus.
Sandy Claws.
Good, good.
Oh, sorry.
Let me put the notice above.
There we go.
Thank you.
Silent night or silver bells.
Yeah, I can do those.
Let's see.
Silent night or silver bells.
Silver bells.
Is that all they do is silver bells?
That's all it does, right?
The site isn't working.
I know they are working on it.
I'm so sorry.
Shadow Claws, X for the 5 gifted.
White Christmas.
I can do that one too.
Let me make a net list.
Snow Halation.
White Christmas.
Silver bells, maybe.
All I want for Christmas.
Though I was going to do that one anyway.
Last Christmas, right?
Last Christmas.
It didn't give me something.
It didn't give me an error though.
It's empty I think for now.
I think they are working on it.
They are working on it guys.
They are working on it.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
It looks different.
You can see some of the stuff.
I think maybe.
Maybe.
I like how it says Birch countdown timer for me.
OK.
Sorry guys.
While you guys...
While you guys refresh I'll sing another song for you.
Here.
I'll sing something to...
Let's do... What was it?
Silver bells?
Or wait.
Silent Night.
We can do that one.
I can try my best.
All is calm, all is bright.
Round yon Virgin, Mother and Child.
Holy infant so tender and mild.
Sleep in heavenly peace.
Silent night, holy night.
Shepherds quake at the sight.
Glories stream from heaven afar.
Heavenly hosts sing alleluia.
Christ the Savior is born.
Silent night, holy night.
Son of God, love's pure light.
Radiant beams from thy holy face.
With dawn of redeeming grace.
Jesus Lord at thy birth...
The timing got weird.
Sorry.
Why is it so fast?
They were like rushing me through the song.
They were like hurry it up kid.
We got to get to all the old people here.
Keep it up.
Silent night.
Hurry night.
What is this tempo?
Why was it so fast?
Wrap it up.
Sorry everybody if the site is still being weird.
They are working on it.
I promise.
Is this song a memory of the crashed website?
I don't know.
Stop telling me how many people are here.
I don't look at that.
Let's do another one.
What was it?
Silver Bells, right?
Wish I could watch.
I need to play Project Wingman.
Have fun with it.
Wish I could watch, but I must play Project Wingman.
Haven't felt the Christmas spirit in over 10 years.
Maybe your wonderful singing and vibes.
We are Christmasing it up today.
No worries.
Del, thank you for the 20 gifted.
Honestly kind of amazed.
So funny.
OK, let me do this one.
I think I know this one well enough maybe.
Actually I don't think I know it well enough actually, but that's OK.
I'll give it to someone special.
Last Christmas I gave you my heart, but the very next day you gave it away.
This year to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
I don't know the Brain Romp versions of all the songs, but if I sing Brain Romp Monster Mash, I'm in the run.
But if you guys sing a Brain Romp version, you guys are mine.
This is double standards.
Once bitten and twice shy.
I keep my distance, but you still catch my eye.
Tell me baby, do you recognize me?
Well, it's been a year, it doesn't surprise me.
Oh my god, I wrapped it up and sent it with a note saying I love you.
I meant it.
Now I know what a fool I've been.
But if you kiss me now, I know you'll fool me again.
Last Christmas I gave you my heart, but the very next day you gave it away.
This year to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Friends
with tired eyes and your soul of ice.
My god, I thought you were someone to rely on.
Me, I guess I was a shoulder to cry on.
Face of a lover with a fire in his heart.
A man undercover, but you tore me apart.
Oh, now I found a real love and you'll never fool me again.
Last Christmas I gave you my heart, but the very next day you gave it away.
This year to save me from tears, I'll give it to someone special.
Face of a lover with a fire in his heart.
A man undercover, but you tore me apart.
Next year.
I'll give it to someone.
I'll give it to someone special.
Special.
Someone.
OK, I'm over it.
I'm over it now.
F5.
Oh, David!
Thank you for the Akasupa.
He got onto the bed and wrenched open the lattice, bursting as he pulled... What is this?
What is this?
What is this, David?
I'm scared.
What am I reading?
Is the store up?
The link still shows me not things on the page.
I'm so sorry, you guys, for the trouble.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry for the trouble.
The docusite is working.
Oh, good!
If you want to get that.
You don't have to, obviously.
Yubi yubi, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Let's keep singing songs.
That's...
That's from last Christmas.
Wait, what did I sing after Sandy Claus?
Shoot, I keep forgetting.
I sing...
Um...
Silent Night.
Oh, thank you!
Silent Night and then 12 was last Christmas.
OK, let's do another Christmas.
What's the docu link?
Oh, let me ask for it.
Let me see, let me see.
Waiting for them to send it to me.
OK, I'm going to sing while I wait.
But the docus are not limited or anything, so don't worry.
What's this one?
Oh wait, there's also this song.
I'll do this one.
Oh wait, OK.
I'll do it after.
Sorry guys, sorry.
I used to know where the treetops glisten and children listen to hear sleigh bells in the snow.
I'm dreaming of a white Christmas with every Christmas card I write.
May your days be merry and bright and may all your Christmases be white.
I'm dreaming of a white Christmas just like the ones I used to know.
Where the treetops glisten and children listen to hear sleigh bells in the snow.
I'm dreaming of a white Christmas with every Christmas card I write.
I don't think I like this song.
Sorry.
I was thinking of a different song.
I was thinking of the roasted chestnuts.
And may all your Christmases be white.
I was thinking of the chestnuts.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry for being so unserious.
I got like bored of it in the middle.
Because I'm so concerned about the website.
I'm like, ah, because so many people are freaking out about it in the chat and making it hard for me to be like, oh yeah.
And I'm like, oh no.
That's why it's hard for me to focus.
It'll get fixed.
Hopefully.
I mean it will, but you know.
Will this cover Santa Tell Me by Ariana Grande?
I don't know.
I could try Wabai, but I don't know it so much.
I just know that...
Another rest.
Okay, let me do chestnuts now.
Oh wait, there's a Celine Dion version?
Wait, is it Carpenters?
No, right?
No, I don't know actually.
Where can I find merch?
There's a link in the pin message, but maybe I'll just link this instead.
Merch.
Maybe I'll link that instead.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, hold on.
Ah, wait.
Merch.
Doki.
Thank you.
There we go.
Two different links.
Replace.
That should work.
It doesn't have everything, but there's some stuff there at least.
But I want the main link to work because it has everything.
This doesn't have everything.
Because it's missing the little blocks, but there's a plushie on there.
Oh yeah, I forgot to say that the plushie comes with the keychain too.
The plushie comes with the keychain too.
ToraDora?
Oh my gosh.
It's Christmas.
I have to see if I can find that one.
Let me see if this is the version of the song.
Wrong one.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to try this one.
Wait.
Oh wait.
Maybe it is the right one.
Hold on.
Maybe I'm stupid.
I'll just do this one.
Pumped up tiger.
Thank you very much.
Jack Frost nipping at your nose.
Yuletide carols being sung by a choir and folks dressed up like Eskimos.
Everybody knows a turkey and some mistletoe help to make the season bright.
Tiny tots with their eyes all aglow will find it hard to sleep tonight.
They know that Santa's on his way.
He's loaded lots of toys and goodies on his sleigh.
And every mother's child is going to spy to see if reindeer really know how to fly.
And so I'm offering this simple phrase to kids from one to ninety-two.
Oh, it's been said many times, many ways, Merry Christmas to you.
Oh, it's been said many times, many ways, Merry Christmas, Merry Christmas,
Merry Christmas.
Let me see.
I saw some people say the original link works now.
No, I'm not seeing.
Still not seeing it.
Chestnuts roasting on an open fire.
Even if I can't get any merch, we get to spend time with you and that's worth eight minto plushies.
Stop!
What do you mean?
Sorry, Pyra, I just saw your thing.
Yes, I have a concert coming up next weekend.
Not this seventh weekend, but the fourteenth weekend.
Live in Atlanta, Georgia with Doki at the Tabernacle in Atlanta, Georgia.
I think I already said that.
Yes, tickets are up.
You can look up Phantom Thief concert and you'll see us.
We have other people such as Doobie as a special guest and Phoebe and Pia.
Junna.
I'm missing one.
Right?
Or was it the three of them?
Phoebe, Pia...
Phoebe, Pia, Junna.
How about Doki?
I said Doki earlier.
I said me and Doki.
And Doobie.
Pia, Phoebe, Junna, Doobie are special guests and it's me and Doki's concert.
Yes, you forgot Mint.
It's me, Drew and Minto.
Hold on, my chat is broken again.
Everything is breaking.
My computer is breaking.
My new monitors are breaking.
The website is breaking.
I'm stressed.
I'm stressing.
I'm stressing a little.
Goodness.
And I also have a goal of 300k by the end of this year.
And I'm only 8k away.
I say only as if that's not a lot.
But I'm 8k away.
And I have merchandise.
And I have too many things to talk about.
I don't have enough brain cells.
Oh gosh.
I'm so excited for the merchandise.
Thank you!
My goal is 300k by the end of the year.
So, we'll see.
I'm 8k away.
So hopefully, we'll see.
I'll do my best.
Shino, thanks for the 20 gifts!
I'm checking the site one more time.
Oh...
Nope.
OK, let's sing...
Let's sing some anime songs.
The color of this special season Makes my heart race
Ever since we first met The melody of my heart I can't stop it, I can't stop it Why?
Should I call out your name When I'm in pain?
Snow Halation Until our feelings overlap I can't wait It's frustrating, but I like it Even if I hesitate in the heat I can't help it I agree with the courage to jump in It's about to start
Fate changes quietly My heart beats faster For the future 例えば 恋は すぐ 駆けつけて 抱きしめたくて 何処にいても 何処でも fly high 急いで いつの間にか 大きくなりすぎた true emotion
夢だけ見てるようじゃ 辛いよ 恋人は 君でいたい 優しい目が 止まってる 嫌だよ このまま一気に愛情 預けて please
Meet the flintstones, they're the modern stonage family From the town of bedrock, they're a page right out of history Someday maybe Fred will win the fight Then the cat will stay out for the night When you're with the flintstones Have a yabba dabba do time,
a dabba do time Do yabba dabba do.
Do yabba dabba dabba do.
Yabba dabba dabba dabba do.
We'll have a gay old time.
Doing that part is way too much fun to not do it.
Do yabba dabba do.
Do yabba dabba dabba do.
Let's see.
What is that song called?
What is that Toradora song called?
Holy Night!
Thank you.
I wonder if they have a karaoke Holy Night.
Like on YouTube.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I should...
This says karaoke, but I wonder.
Let's see.
Hold on.
I'm looking into the future.
Now do the Flintstones version.
Let me see.
Oh, here.
I just turned it off.
Let me try if this is...
This is it?
Holy Night!
Maybe it's better if it sounds like a bad quality.
Hopefully I don't get taken down for this.
That's not it.
I don't remember the... I think I remember the verses.
I don't remember.
I'm sorry.
Holy Night!
This song makes me cry!
I think of the time.
Holy Night!
Party Night!
Christmas!
I think of
that scene where Taiga goes to her apartment and Ryuji is there dressed up as the bear.
And she just gives him the big hug and then they spin around.
And then she cries, but then she runs after him, but he's gone.
Do they kiss?
Not in that scene, but Toradora still has the greatest anime kiss scene ever.
Fight me.
It's the greatest anime kiss ever, ever, ever.
It's so beautiful.
It's so...
God!
Oh my gosh.
I love that.
I love the whole anime.
I used to watch... I haven't in many, many years now, but I used to watch or re-watch Toradora during Christmas time just so I could re-watch the Christmas episode!
I sneaked in an order while everyone was clapping.
Are the orders going through?
Let's go!
Oh my gosh.
Wait!
The main link works now!
If you wanted to block me though.
Let me...merge.
Doki...Doki site.
Wait, hold on.
Let me grab the Doki site.
OK, use this link instead so you can see everything.
Replace.
Yay!
If you want to block.
The mythical block.
Oh, I gotta do that too.
And then it shows the other official...fan official items.
I defeated the website connection demons.
Order.
Yay!
OK.
The Booba mousepad is not accurate.
It's also not mine.
It is fan merch.
I think they also host fan merch on their site.
So there's some stuff.
So basically how it works is...
The super cool exclusive items are the limited stuff that is...
That is like...I've purchased that essentially.
Like I pre-bought those with my own money.
And I get most of the stuff, most of the money from those.
And then the fan official items are items that with my approval and me and Moso working together...
We made those fan official items.
So I still get a cut.
But like...yeah.
And yeah, the plush comes with the keychain.
They told me that shipping should go out maybe around like...
Depending on what you get, around mid to late January.
I was able to get my order through and it looks like it's working for other people as well.
Yay!
I hope that takes a little bit off of your mind.
Thanks for putting me in the Christmas spirit today.
Yeah!
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Fighting for my order to go through.
Before it crashed and it got fixed again.
Yeah, it went through!
Oh, yatta!
Thank you guys for getting the plushie and the box.
I'm sorry for the troubles.
It seems that things are going smooth, smooth.
Oh, give this link.
Yeah, I think that's the one I can put up.
Let me make sure.
Yay!
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee, yippee!
Cool!
I'm happy.
Let's see.
Oh, let me add to the setlist.
Snow Halation and then...
Holy Night ToraDora insert song.
So people don't get confused.
Guys, is it okay if I don't sing some Christmas song?
I've been in a totally absolutely wicked mood recently.
All I want to sing and listen to is wicked.
It's kind of Christmas because it came out recently, right?
I just want to sing Wicked the musical.
Wait, Wicked musical.
Please loathing?
I can maybe do... I don't know who's part I sing usually.
Let's try it.
Sorry, these are just... I just get these out of my system.
I'm really sorry.
Oh my god.
Wait, I need someone to sing with me.
Elphaba.
Blonde.
Curve it as a flame.
Does it have a name?
Yes.
Loathing.
Unadulterated loathing.
For your face, your voice, your clothing.
Let's just say I loathe it all.
Every little trait, however small, makes my very flesh begin to crawl.
With the utter loathing, there's a strange exhilaration.
In such total devastation, it's so pure, it's so strong.
Though I do admit it came on fast, still I do believe that it can last.
And I will be loathing, loathing you my whole life long.
Dear Galinda, you are just too good.
How do you stand it?
I don't think I could.
She's a terror, she's a tartar, we don't mean to show a bite.
This is me to Matara.
Well, these things are sent to try us.
Poor Galinda, forced to be side with someone so disgustigified.
We just want to tell you...
Everybody thinks she's disgusting!
We share your loathing.
What is this feeling so sudden and new?
I felt the moment I laid eyes on you.
My pulse is rushing, my head is reeling.
Oh, what is this feeling?
Does it have a name?
It's loathing.
There's a strange exhilaration in such total distastation.
It's so pure, it's so strong.
Though I do admit it came on fast, still I do believe that it can last.
And I will be loathing for forever.
Loathing truly, deeply, loathing you.
My whole life long.
The plushie sold out?
Wait, actually?
Actually?
It's not a large number.
It is for me!
Do you know how much that cost me out of my pocket?
It's out of my pocket.
It was a lot of money.
I couldn't order anymore.
It's
like the longest intro ever.
Good news.
She's dead.
The western, the west is dead.
The wickedest witch there ever was.
The enemy of all of us here in Oz is dead.
Good news.
I'll try and restock them someday.
Look!
It's Glinda!
Fellow Ozians.
Let us be glad.
Let us be grateful.
Let us rejoiceify that goodness could subdue the wicked workings of you-know.
Isn't it nice to know that good will conquer evil.
The truth will all believe.
I am born only for you.
No one mourns the wicked.
No one cries they won't return.
No one lays a lily on their grave.
A good man scorns the wicked.
In their lives our children learn what we miss when we misbehave.
And goodness knows the wicked's lives are lonely.
Goodness knows the wicked die alone.
It just shows when you're wicked you're left only on your own.
Goodness knows the wicked's lives are lonely.
Goodness knows the wicked cry alone.
Nothing grows for the wicked.
They reap only what they sow.
Are people born wicked?
Or do they have wickedness thrust upon them?
After all, she had a father.
She had a mother.
As so many do.
How I hate to go and leave you lonely.
It's alright, it's only just one night.
I forgot about this part.
But know that you're here in my heart, your soul.
And, like every family, they had their secrets.
Have another drink, my dark-eyed beauty.
I've got one more night left here in town.
So have another drink, a green elixir.
And we'll have ourselves a little mixer.
Have another little swallow, little lady, and follow me now.
And of course, from the moment she was born, she was...
well...
different.
I thought this was a separate song.
I know.
The baby's coming!
I see a nose!
Oh god!
I'm birthing the baby!
What is it?
What's wrong?
Could it be?
What does it mean?
It's atrocious!
It's obscene!
Like a froggy, ferny cabbage, the baby is unnaturally green!
And then he says something.
He's like, Go away!
Oh, there he goes.
He said it.
Take it away!
Have you guys ever seen The Wicked?
So you see, it couldn't have been easy!
I don't remember this part.
I remember this part.
We know what wickedness is!
She died alone!
Won't you know?
Who's spurned what goodness is?
They are shy!
No one knows the wickedness!
No one knows!
Wickedness!
Oh, shit.
I can't hit high notes very easily anymore.
I didn't...
It's...
It's as long as your mind in the movie.
Or is that in the second act?
I can't remember.
OK, let me do two more songs.
I'm sorry.
I'll do this one and I'll do Defying Gravity and all whatever.
It's in the second act.
Oh, so you haven't heard it yet.
Oh, shoot.
I like this song though.
Wait.
Fierro.
41 of Minto Plushie.
Wait, what?
No!
I will try to do a pre-order, you guys!
Lying beside you.
Hold on, wait a second.
Oh, wait.
Want me to uncap the plushies?
They're sold out.
I can arrange more.
Oh.
I think they're gonna try and put more up.
Maybe.
I'm seeing if we can do pre-order or something.
For you guys.
Sorry.
Sorry, that's what I was messaging back about.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, let me start over.
Lying beside you.
With you wanting me.
And just for this moment.
This is about the plushies.
As long as you're mine.
I've lost all resistance.
Across some borderline.
And if it turns out.
It's over too fast.
I'll make every last moment last.
As long as you're mine.
I think there's more of you guys.
Check, check, check, check, check, check.
Check while this guy's singing.
We don't care about this guy.
We don't care about him.
Check, check, check, check.
Man singing.
Get out of here.
Every moment.
As long as you're mine.
I'll wake up my body.
And make up for lost time.
And though.
I may know.
I don't care.
Just for this moment.
As long as you're mine.
Cook me how you want to.
And see how bright we shine.
Borrow the moonlight.
Until it is through.
I'll be here.
Holding you.
As long as you're mine.
What is it?
Oh, it's just for the first time.
I feel wicked.
I
think for the extra plushies that they're putting up.
They're not like.
They're, they're, they are.
Like, what's it called?
Since I ordered a specific amount.
We will have to order more.
You know what I mean?
So, if you get one now.
It will be maybe a little bit.
Yeah, it's like a pre-order basically.
Yeah, it's basically like a pre-order.
So, I just have to make some more.
Well, I mean, it took me.
I was in the works for it like.
For many months.
It took a long, long time.
So, it shouldn't take as long.
Because it's not like me going through a.
What's the word?
Like a process of me being like.
Okay, getting the design.
And then getting it shipped to me.
And then me checking.
And then me giving the okay.
And then this, that, that.
You know what I mean?
No design phase.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, hopefully, everybody gets them in a timely manner.
Should be at least a little bit faster.
Honestly, everything took so long.
Just because I was like.
I don't really have a storefront.
And I don't really have a way to ship stuff out.
I've never had a storefront before.
I didn't know how.
I was like.
Oh, gosh.
I'm going to be doing fulfillment for years.
And I.
So, I was like.
Okay, I'll go with Moso.
Because I.
Well, also, the people helping my plushie.
Making my plushie.
Recommended them.
And then also, I was like.
Okay.
They just told me.
Aiming for June.
For the second round of the plushies.
So, sorry.
It's going to take some time.
So, yeah.
But that's for the second batch.
For the people that just got theirs.
It's sooner.
So, yeah.
That's for the first batch of the ones.
Will be much sooner.
Like, next month-ish.
Probably.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry.
Is Dakimakura print on demand?
Dakimakura is print on demand.
But it is up for a limited amount of time.
Because it is Isekai Minto.
Minto with...
From another world.
So, after this though.
You will not be able to get it again.
It is up for a limited time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Not to say that there won't be another Dakimakura in the future.
But it will be a little bit different.
So, yeah.
What's the end date?
I believe it's the end of this month.
Unfortunately, I don't have a direct...
I don't have an exact date right now.
Dayui is an amazing artist.
I know!
I knew that I wanted to go with Dayui.
Love their art so much.
Okay.
I guess maybe I'll end with one last song.
Of course, I must sing this Christmas song.
Not Isekai Minto Daki soon.
I wanna say soon.
Let's do one more song.
She is thought.
Oh, Defying Gravity.
Defying Gravity.
Okay, hold on.
Let me do it.
I forgot that I was gonna sing that one too.
I forgot I was gonna sing Defying Gravity.
I will be...
I'll be...
Oh.
Elphaba.
Why couldn't you have stayed calm for once instead of flying off the handle?
I hope you're happy.
I hope you're happy now.
I hope you're happy how you hurt your cause forever.
I hope you think you're clever.
I hope you're happy.
I hope you're happy too.
I hope you're proud how you worked through all of this submission to feed your own ambition.
So though I can't imagine how, I hope you're happy right now.
Elphie, listen to me.
Just say you're sorry.
You can still be with the wizard.
What you worked and waited for.
You can have all you ever wanted.
I know.
But I don't want it.
This Elphaba's funny.
I can't want it anymore.
Alright, I'm gonna take over Elphaba for a second.
I'm sorry.
Something has changed within me.
Something is not the same.
I'm through with playing by the rules of someone else's game.
Too late for second guessing.
Too late to go back to sleep.
It's time to trust my instincts.
Close my eyes.
And leave.
It's time to try defying gravity.
I think I'll try defying gravity.
And you can't pull me down.
I make you understand.
You're having delusions of grandeur.
I'm through accepting limits.
Cause someone says they're so.
Some things I cannot change.
But till I try, I'll never know.
Too long I've been afraid of losing love.
I guess I've lost.
Well, if that's love, it comes at much too high of a cost.
I'd sooner find defying gravity.
Kiss me goodbye.
I'm defying gravity.
And you can't pull me down.
Glinda, let's hold space for the lyrics of this song.
Together.
Unlimited.
Together we're unlimited.
Together we'll be the greatest team there's ever been.
Glinda dreams the way we planned them.
If we work in tandem, there's no fight we cannot win.
Just you and I, defying gravity.
With you and I, defying gravity.
They'll never bring us down.
Now that you're choosing this.
You too.
I hope it brings you bliss.
I really hope you get it.
And you don't live to regret it.
I hope you're happy in the end.
I hope you're happy, my friend.
So if you care to find me.
Look to the western sky.
As someone told me lately.
Everyone deserves the chance to fly.
And if I'm flying solo.
At least I'm flying free.
To those who ground me.
Take a message back from me.
Tell them how I am defying gravity.
I'm flying high.
I'm defying gravity.
And soon I'll match them in renown.
And nobody.
In all of us.
No wizard that there is or was.
Is ever gonna bring me down.
Bring me down.
Damn, I can't hold those notes for shit.
I can't hold it.
It's because I'm hungry.
When I get hungry I get all shaky.
And then I get shaky and my voice gets weaky.
Minky!
Go get food.
I have one last song.
That's what I was like.
I'm thinking of food.
I'm not thinking of singing anymore.
I'm hungry.
Alrighty.
Minky!
Let's sing the Christmas special, baby!
I think you guys like my outfit.
It's cute, right?
Hopefully this helps you get into the Christmas spirit a little bit more.
Don't want a lot for Christmas.
There is just one thing I need.
I don't care about the presents.
Underneath the Christmas tree.
I just want you for my own.
More than you could ever know.
Make my wish come true.
All I want for Christmas is you.
Love for Christmas.
There is just one thing I need.
And I...
I don't need to hang my stocking.
There upon the fireplace.
Santa Claus won't make me happy.
With a toy on Christmas day.
I just want you for my own.
More than you could ever know.
Make my wish come true.
All I want for Christmas is you.
You, baby.
Oh, I won't ask for much this Christmas.
I won't even wish for snow.
I'm just gonna keep on waiting.
Underneath the...
Merry Cootie, Merry Cootie.
I love that because...
For the plant North Pole for St. Nick.
I won't even stay awake to...
Hear those magic reindeers click.
Cause I just want you here tonight.
Holding on to me so tight.
What more can I do?
All I want for Christmas is you.
You, baby.
All the lights are shining so brightly everywhere.
And the sound of children's laughter fills the air.
And everyone is singing.
I hear those sleigh bells ringing.
Santa, won't you bring me the one I really need?
Won't you please bring my baby to me?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I don't want a lot for Christmas.
This is all I'm asking for.
I just want to see my baby standing right outside my door.
Oh, I just want you for my own.
More than you could ever know.
Make my wish come true.
All I want for Christmas is you.
All
I want for Christmas is you, baby.
You.
All I want for Christmas is you, baby.
Merry Christmas!
Is you.
Thank you guys for the merch.
I've been selling out the merch.
I saw the Outsiders musical.
Yes, that's why I love the Outsiders so much.
Gosh, I think I'm not okay.
I love Doomdiowee and Doomdeary too much.
Knocked it out of the park.
Thank you, Valentine,
with it.
I can't wait to see all the pictures of the Minto to go.
I can't wait to see everybody taking pictures with their Minto plushies and other merch.
The little blocks and the keychains and the diorama and the stickers and everything.
Yeah!
Thank you guys!
Merch site shenanigans.
Sorry, I'm really still... I'm shaking because I was so nervous.
I got so hyped up and then I also... I'm hungry.
Congratulations on being able to have such a huge merch drop.
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I really, really appreciate it.
I appreciate you guys.
I'm... sorry.
Selling out.
I'm going to go eat now so I can stop hyperventilating.
Otsu Minto!
Thank you everybody!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Have a good night!
I need some water.
Have a good day!
Merikuri, Merikuri.
Presento, presento.
Bye bye!
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye!